[Música]
esa es una clínica de verdad
Pero eso no
estamos en Estados Unidos y esto es lo
que llaman un centro para embarazos no
deseados hay miles de estos que esta
activista Pro aborto denuncia en este
vídeo para atraer a las pacientes estas
clínicas fingen ser centrosas de abortos
Auténticos pero de puertas adentro se
hace todo lo posible para desalentar la
interrupción del embarazo el 24 de junio
pasado la Corte Suprema de Estados
Unidos permitió a los estados de la
Unión Americana prohibir totalmente el
aborto y desde entonces los activistas
han hecho sonar las alarmas sobre lo que
han denominado clínicas falsas nuestra
observadora fue una de estas clínicas en
Tennessee pensando que encontraría
información sobre métodos
anticonceptivos
cuando pregunté por los anticonceptivos
me dieron todo un discurso diciéndome
que no había que confiar en los
anticonceptivos que eran peligrosos y
que afectarían mi salud y que la única
opción era no tener nunca relaciones
sexuales jamás
había muchos folletos y carteles llenos
de mentiras como decir que el aborto
provoca cáncer de mama o depresión o que
afectará tu fertilidad en el futuro todo
lo cual se ha demostrado que es falso
una y otra vez
entre las técnicas utilizadas para
disuadir a las mujeres y abortar la
falsas clínicas distribuyen por ejemplo
bolsas llenas de regalos como grabó una
de nuestras observadoras
lo cual no es así
estos centros de embarazos no deseados
tienen una gran variedad de tácticas
para atraer a la gente a algunas de
ellas se instalan deliberadamente cerca
de clínicas de aborto reales para que
sus voluntarios se hagan frente a estas
clínicas intenten convencer a las
pacientes de que vayan a su clínica
falsa en su lugar veo aún más tácticas
deshonestas por su parte por ejemplo
ponen una furgoneta para hacer
ecografías fuera de las clínicas de
aborto e intentan que los pacientes
vayan a sus furgonetas diciendo somos de
la clínica esto es parte de su cita
estos lugares reciben mucha financiación
reciben dinero público en muchos estados
para funcionarse
pueden mentirles a las pacientes y
decirles lo que quieran porque no son
clínicas reales
según la organización expose fake
clínics en septiembre 2022 había más de
250.000 clínicas falsas en todo Estados
Unidos en comparación con unas 800
clínicas de aborto
antes de que se anulará El Cachorro
contra buey teníamos ocho edificios que
prestaban servicios de aborto en todo el
estado de Tennessee y algo así como 11
veces más clínicas falsas hay mucho caos
y confusión en este momento la gente no
sabe si el acceso al aborto Es legal en
su estado o no
Y eso podría cambiar cualquier día en
muchos estados los centros para
embarazos no deseados confían que así
sea quieren que la gente no sepa dónde
ir y acabe yendo a la clínica falsada en
los estados donde no hay clínicas de
aborto en
[Música]
Qatar protestar puede resultar muy caro
en este vídeo se ven trabajadores de la
construcción todos de países extranjeros
el 14 de agosto se concentraron frente a
la sede de la empresa que los empleaba
para exigir siete meses de salarios no
pagados más de 60 manifestantes fueron
detenidos el 23 de agosto y varios de
ellos fueron expulsados de ese país eran
empleados de Albany una empresa
especializada en la construcción de
hoteles y residencias de lujo nuestro
observador lleva tres años viviendo en
Qatar donde trabajaba como guardia de
seguridad recientemente visitó las
viviendas de estos trabajadores y nos da
testimonios ocultamos su rostro
se ven las camas y todo eso parece una
ciudad basura solían vivir aquí muchos
de ellos fueron deportados de hecho y
esta era su vivienda
dejaron sus maletas sus pertenencias
todo los salarios no pagados son un
fenómeno común en catar
como nos explicó maxton un director de
la oficina internacional de trabajo en
roja Este es un problema común en el
sector de la construcción en el sector
de la construcción hay un primer nivel
de subcontratistas un segundo nivel un
tercer nivel y a veces el dinero tarda
mucho en llegar al final de la cadena y
al final son los trabajadores Quienes no
reciben su sueldo las cosas van bien en
su empresa hay problemas con la empresa
los salarios no se pagan todos los meses
llevo tres meses quizá cuatro sin que me
paguen no le han pagado no me han pagado
cuánto tiempo lleva viviendo en Qatar
desde hace cinco años seis años bajo la
presión de las ong internacionales
Qatar creo un organismo para recoger las
quejas de los trabajadores no
remunerados en 2018 el país creó un
fondo para compensarlos pero los
procedimientos son demasiado largos
según Max tunon los trabajadores tienen
un mejor acceso a estos canales pero lo
que vemos es que a menudo toma mucho
tiempo en que los trabajadores llegan al
final de este proceso por ejemplo el año
pasado vimos un aumento significativo de
las quejas entre 2020 y 2021 cuando
observamos los datos Y cuando vemos el
tiempo que lleva conseguir una audiencia
en el tribunal de trabajo o conseguir
salarios e indemnizaciones una vez que
el fallo fue a su favor
eso es lo más problemático hoy en día
según la oficina Internacional del
trabajo este fondo ha indemnizado a
7.000 trabajadores por más de 160
millones de dólares pero no hay datos
precisos sobre el número de trabajadores
extranjeros que aún no ha sido
indemnizados
[Música]
de esta forma llegamos al final de
nuestra emisión de los observadores todo
nuestro contactos aparecen en pantalla
si nos quiere hacer llegar sus vídeos
aficionados hasta una próxima
oportunidad